when a Muslim scholar is forced to admit
that Jesus died by crucifixion you
should listen
for nearly 14 centuries the vast
majority of Muslims have denied Jesus
death on the cross the most popular view
has always been some version of
substitution Theory the claim that Allah
miraculously disguised someone else to
make him look like Jesus and that this
other person was crucified in Jesus
place
there are three main problems with the
standard Islamic narrative one Scholars
actual historians regard Jesus death by
crucifixion as an indisputable fact of
history two the Quran affirms the
inspiration preservation and authority
of the Christian scriptures and the
Christian scriptures are quite clear
that Jesus died by crucifixion three the
Islamic view portrays Allah as a cosmic
trickster who deceives people about His
prophets Allah tricked people into
believing that Jesus died
fortunately there have always been a
minority of Muslims who aren't scared to
point out the holes in the standard
Islamic narrative take Sheikh Imran
Hussein
in a lecture about the Quran and the
Messiah Sheikh Imran eventually
discusses the crucifixion of Jesus it
begins by saying that Jesus only
appeared to die which sounds like the
standard Islamic narrative
when they saw him die on the cross
they were convinced he could not have
been the Messiah
one day did not know
was it Allah made it appeared to them
that he was crucified
but then he clarifies what it really
means to be crucified and what it really
means to die first crucifixion
what's the definition of crucifixion
it is that you should die
by hanging on the cross
so crucifixion isn't simply nailing
someone to a cross it's the person dying
by nailing him to a cross but what does
it mean to die what is the definition
of death
the definition of death
is it Allah should send the angels to
take the soul
and not return it
is there anyone who defers with me
to die to really die is to have your
soul taken away and not returned this is
important for what he's about to say so
he repeats it the definition of death
is it Allah should take the soul
and not return it can Allah take the
soul and return it tell the school boy
go back and study the Quran
so what does the Quran mean in Surah 4
verse 157 when it says that Allah made
it appear as if Jesus died
get ready for an epic rant so then what
did Allah do to make it appear
that he died
let me warn you
and my language is sometimes very harsh
because that's the only language some
people can understand
some people can only understand
harsh language
got it shake thanks for the cosign on
the Unstoppable fire hose of sarcasm and
mockery that is
D wood
don't come with this nonsense
because it is not only pathetic nonsense
it is absolutely sinful
to say that Allah
Allah calls someone else to take the
appearance
and that innocent man innocent because
he never claimed to be in the Muslim he
was crucified so the standard Islamic
narrative way to a judgment day with
that nonsense
pathetic nonsense it's not there in the
Quran it's in your imagination
that's the way it is and yet it took the
world of Islam by storm what a brainwash
Uma we are today he ain't lying
well then what happened well then why
don't you go to the Quran let the Quran
explain rather than go on fancy flights
of imagination
you cause that man to assume the
appearance of someone
and he who never came to be the Messiah
he was crucified that was an act of
Injustice you attributing Injustice to
Allah what foolishness he's right
absolute foolishness but it's what
Muslims tell me every single day
Allah took his soul
they thought he was dead
they took down the body
they put their body in the cave
they sailed the cave
Allah returned so
as simple as that nobody knew that the
body that the soul was returned
and Allah raised him
so while Jesus was on the cross Allah
took his soul meaning that he was dead
in the biological sense his body was
taken down from the cross and put in the
Tomb but then Allah returned Jesus soul
to his body meaning he didn't die in the
stricter sense the Sheikh is talking
about he wasn't dead in the sense of
Allah taking away the soul and not
returning it Allah did return his soul
so Jesus rose from biological death
but since so many Muslims have been
indoctrinated with substitution Theory
how about another warning Shake
but let me warn you one more time
if you stick with this theory of
substitution you are going to be in a
pathetic state on Judgment Day let me
warn you one more time this is a simple
explanation from the Quran
and so
he did not die
Jesus didn't die in the sense that
Sheikh Imran is talking about he died in
the normal sense of the word died he was
crucified in the normal sense of the
word crucified but given more specific
meanings of these terms Jesus wasn't
killed and wasn't crucified now it may
sound as if Sheikh and Ron is just
playing word games here but think about
the point he's making because he may be
right about what the Quran is claiming
the Quran says nothing about Allah
disguising someone else and making him
look like Jesus the Quran simply says
they didn't kill him and didn't crucify
him
in context people are bragging we killed
the Messiah we crucified the Messiah we
got him he's finished
and Allah's response is no you didn't
and no he isn't
could Allah just be saying look you
think that by beating Jesus and
crucifying him and stabbing him through
the heart with a spear and burying him
that you've killed him but you're wrong
because I can just raise him from the
dead
couldn't Allah simply be telling people
that the enemies of Jesus didn't
accomplish what they were trying to
accomplish
I think this view Sheikh and Ron's view
is massively superior to the standard
Islamic narrative which rejects all of
history rejects multiple sources that
Muhammad and Allah confirmed and
portrays Allah as a cosmic trickster who
deceives people for no reason
but this leads to an important question
a question for Muslims
my Muslim friends
if you've been wrong about Jesus death
and Resurrection for nearly 14 centuries
what else are you wrong about
[Music]